sumo wrestling has been around for over
a thousand years
and while the sport is steeped in
tradition it is still
evolving from american wrestlers to
women allowed in
amateur championships here are four
stories about the wide world of sumo
how
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
next
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
consumer wrestling is a game of seconds
[Music]
however there's months
of training that go within those seconds
imagine it's like an earthquake that's
building
and building and building and all of a
sudden there's this
huge explosion all
at one time that's what symbol is
[Music]
i'm really just a normal guy i'm a
husband
i'm a father of three i'm the director
of technology for the county office of
education
also an american consumer essay
sumo has a long history in japan some
people trace it back up to
1500 or 2 000 years but it's essentially
you know wrestling where you either want
to push your opponent out of the ring
or knock your opponent to the ground
people have an image that sumo wrestlers
are basically just bumping bellies and
wobbling around
and as you can see from the practice
here nothing's further from the truth
roy's amazing he basically came out of
nowhere he showed up to the 2014 us sumo
open
and blew everyone's mind he beat every
single american opponent
with almost no training he's already the
number one american
[Music]
to be a competitive sumo wrestler you
need to
train hard whether i'm stretching
whether i'm powerlifting whether i'm
working out with with rocks
i'm always looking for the
the edge that really brought me to sumo
was the fact that there was
culture and sport all kind of mixed in
one it
seemed like a perfect fit for example
when you
stomp the ground you're ridding the area
of bad spirits
and when you make your first clap you're
waking up the gods
you know he is a gentle giant and he
doesn't want to hurt anybody and
sumo's great that way because you know
they're just trying to get each other
out of the ring they're not trying to
knock each other out or really hurt
hurt one another
[Music]
i think sumo has that camaraderie
fraternity
aspect to it you know we're banging
heads we're going at it
at the end of it there's still this high
level of respect
i guess as a pacifist that definitely
appeals to me
amami oshima is an island off the coast
of mainland japan
and while it's well known for its
thriving coral reefs and sandy beaches
it's sumo that puts this island on the
map
[Music]
amami oshima takes great pride in
raising young boys to become some of the
country's best wrestlers
[Music]
with over 150 dokios or sumo rings
amami oshima has the highest
concentration of sumo facilities in
japan
making the sport accessible to most
young people on the island
[Music]
stay
[Music]
is
but sumo is not only practiced as a
means for future success
it's a nod to the island's history and
has been embedded in its culture for
hundreds of years
[Music]
annual festivals include sumo
tournaments where wrestlers come out
to participate
but despite the island's efforts to
maintain sumo as a cultural staple
the sport has begun to decrease in
popularity among young people
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]
my
you